- As I was talking about Mexico-They're sending
people. That Mexico doesn't ...
- This came for you today.
- Thank you.
I don't think I ordered this.
- Hmm.
(mysterious orchestral music)
- Oh, those look really good on you.
- Yeah? Alright.
- Yo, bro, let's grab some lunch dude.
Let's go.
- Alright, yeah, okay.
I'll see you later.
- Why are you (mumbles). It's not even ...
Oh-
- Dude!
(whimsical orchestral music)
- Have a good one, bud!
What's up guys!
- Hey, what's up!
Hey!
- How is everything?
- How are you? What's up?
- Nothing.
- Hey, here you go.
Here you go, dude.
I got you some extra ones.
- Dude, I don't want these.
- What do you mean you
don't want this, dog?
I thought you said you wanted
extra, I got you some more dog.
Don't you wnat this?
You know what I had to go
through to get this for you.
- Dude what is this?
- What?
It's what you wanted.
- Are you okay?
- I'm gonna go back to the office.
- What? We just got here.
- No, it's okay.
(mysterious orchestral music)
- Is he okay?
(breathes heavily)
- (laughter) Woah.
(grunts)
Welcome to the gun show.
Hey, there.
(mysterious orchestral music)
- This just came for you.
- I don't think I ordered this.
(mysterious music)